Ladies, stop being victims.
Do you know how many comments I read about women
thinking that it's just for every corporate company
to give them time off for their menstrual cycles
or time off for their pregnancy?
These companies were built by men.
Now, I don't think that we are any more suppressed now
than we were in the last few decades.
I think we have all the freedom in the world in America.
But yes, corporate structure was created by men and the patriarchy.
Not in a negative way, because they built our world.
So the 9 to 5 schedule is conducive to a man.
So if you care about that type of justice so much,
then you go start a company from scratch,
make it go public, build it into a billion dollar empire.
And then you, as a woman,
can decide, I'm going to hire women
and give them time off for their mistral cycles
or for their pregnancy, or for their birth.
But here's what I don't understand.
We have equal opportunity.
But why, as a woman,
would you want to work exactly like a man?
You wanna know why every woman in America is sick,
has adrenal fatigue, has chronic cortisol,
high cortisol levels? Why all of us are hormonally imbalanced
and most of us are now infertile?
Because we decided somewhere,
along with modern feminism,
that it was a good idea to be exactly like men.
So a few years ago, I decided to Honor my body.
Honor my cycle and my hormones.
And learn how to work from home if your family needs that extra income.
And I have helped thousands of women do it.